okay what's something not obviously
sexual that turns me on not obviously
sexual that turns you me on hey I'm Dave
Franco and I'm Allison Brie and this is
the GQ couples quiz
I like to go first and I think that
you're gonna be better at this than me I
think so let's get that out of the way
the first thing to start with a very
easy one what's my middle name Bree your
real last name is skirmerhorn thank you
s-c-h-e-r-m-e-r-h-o-r-n oh my God honey
what's the
sister in me two years
and more specifically you're two years
younger is that what you mean no I mean
like
to refer to our age difference 18 months
22 months 22 months so close to two
years I don't think we've ever talked
about that it's half a point okay when
and what was my acting debut
I want to say it was born
my on screen so we're going with my
on-screen acting debut not not counting
theater or any children child childhood
we're going with on-screen it was born
it was an evil fetus demon fetus
that's right there was something really
gross happening well the demon fetus at
one point my character had sex with a
guy and the demon fetus eats his penis
that's what I was thinking of at another
Point penis eating I'm like making out
with my roommate and she kisses down my
body and the demon fetus burst out my
pregnant belly and pulls her tongue out
of her mouth until she dies you could
say that and then Ridley Scott was maybe
inspired by born for aliens yeah I think
so I think that would be a fair
assessment even though born came after
it's like he knew that that was coming
he knows good answer thank you oh this
is an intro okay okay where was our
first
our first date probably the first real
date was at that little Italian spot on
Larchmont that is now closed that was
our first La date that was like back to
real life we're both like in our normal
routines follow-up what did I think of
you now look I hope you're not gonna
bring up what I think you are I
absolutely am what um potential error do
you think you committed on that our very
first official you remember I was 26
when we met I just didn't know what to
do in fairness and we had hung out a lot
by the time we had our first official
date we had already hung up a bit we
were late to dinner
and uh our first date in L.A I was
freaked out that we were late and
instead of coming up to the door I
honked on the heart you get negative
points three points for admitting and
embarrassing I don't want that sympathy
for you that's a sympathy two points two
points not three not three we know my
Max is really two I just want you to
have all the points thank you what am I
most scared of
I would say
scary movies I think horror movies are
up there where we've gone on a
progression throughout our relationship
where I love horror movies and at first
you wanted nothing to do with them and
then we got to the stage where I was
like okay this one's actually good and
it's worth you being scared for the next
two weeks that's true and now we're
writing horror movies together that's
true but I suggest that we watch a
horror movie almost every night and it's
a little too much that is also true and
yet I don't know if you're gonna get
points for this honey the dark
it's like less the horror movie it's
done at night when we're asleep and I
see into the dark closet and I'm always
like it's gonna get me from the closet I
have a hammer in our our nightstand just
in case what good is that going to be on
my side I got you I got you
between you and me who's the better
actor
I can confidently say you hey I'm gonna
give it to you I'm gonna give it to you
how can you tell when I'm upset
you get a little quiet which is rare for
you
um you should usually constantly fill in
the space I can tell just how you're
reacting to what I'm saying and then
I'll initially try to like dip a toe in
by like making a joke and when you don't
react uh I immediately basically say we
need to confront this so let's get past
it immediately now I know the joke tag
that's correct yes you get a point for
that for sure what are my favorite kind
of flowers I'm gonna say you love
orchids but they're not your favorite
let me finish
I know we had an orchid in our house for
a long time
I mean I'm not really an orchid gal it's
so what is your favorite flower
binoculars how am I supposed to remember
that word I know what's my favorite form
of self-care oh I feel like I have one
and it's pretty specific oh okay and I
do it a lot I got it your weird blanket
thing is it a zip up yeah yeah plop
yourself in front of the TV zip yourself
up and plug it in and what does it do
for you it's an infrared sauna blanket
there you go but what do I most often
watch when I'm doing the sauna blanket
Kardashians definitely there we go
can I try it is it weird that we both
share the same infrared bed no you could
try it because you have to either wear
clothes in it or you do it as I prefer
in the nude and there's like a towel
also like a little towel sleeping bag
blanket that you get in and then I wash
that immediately after every time but
also I have two of them so you could use
one and I have a spray I clean the
inside okay all right I'm gonna go very
sanitary what do you think is the very
first part of my morning bathroom
routine and it's new ish and I try to
get you to do it
got it
the tongue scraper yeah do you do that
every day yes and it has to be first
thing
you don't want to drink any water it's a
little grossed out by it and how much
more gross is it to just let that stuff
stay in the back of your mouth no it's
there no one else used the tongue
scraper people use the tongue spray for
it what's our favorite show to watch
together
do you know this I mean there's like the
current like most Zeitgeist current
White Lotus what might be unique about
when we would watch White Lotus together
you during the theme song the opening
theme song you would slowly get out of
bed and then start doing an interpretive
dance all over the bedroom which would
culminate in you taking off your shirt
then we would watch the episode
when I do that for every episode you did
it for every single episode okay last
question what do I like most about you
it's got a little emotional
I'm actually embarrassed that I got a
little emotional right now
um I think that you like that I'm a good
listener and this is so embarrassing oh
my God
I love it I'm very curious and care
about people a lot and my friends and my
family
that means two points congratulations
honey you got this many points and my
love okay we're all very nervous for you
thank you yes this is a softball what
was my first job ever video store yes
how old was I 14. good answer yes I was
14 years old
um it was actually illegal for me to be
working there at that age they basically
paid me by allowing me to take home as
many movies as I wanted and it was
unpaid child labor I think I got a
little something a little something on
the side but it was the year 1999 which
is now known as one of the greatest
movie years of all time Matrix Fight
Club
American Beauty American Pie
Insider
[Music]
one point one point how do you know when
I'm anxious there's fidgeting you know
what it is the most generic okay it's
your leg tapping tap tap tap tap tap you
will vibrate the whole couch and I will
often just put a little I don't know if
that's out of anxiety that's just a
normal fidgety I think so you just
follow me around the house
talking about all the things it's
probably the most talkative you've ever
been when you're an answer that's the
answer
half a point half a point name my top
three favorite directors of all time
he's probably the one currently that I
would love to work with the most whose
movies there's two I'm thinking of
specifically we watched their entire
filmography almost every year
left every year they both have the same
last name I have the same last name
oh my God
I feel like you're gonna say it and then
I call Thomas Anderson Wes Anderson oh
I was going back we went through our
Cronenberg phase I was I was thinking
about no no no negative one I got Spike
Jones so quickly negative one we can all
agree there's an unfair point system
going on okay what artist inspired me
the most growing up I actually have an
answer for this and you're not gonna get
it how dare I'll give you a hint uh an
author Roald Dahl there you go he thinks
I know nothing because I know what
specific books do you think
witches definitely with my uh what's my
favorite nickname for you
for me yes
yes that not immediately coming off the
tip of your oh
[Laughter]
babe correct one point
um this is a this is existential who am
I the closest with besides you oh
this is interesting your best friends
you've known
School buds I have my family
of course your family who's your mom
would you pinpoint thank your mom I
think my mom
yeah that's the answer what did you
learn about me during quarantine that
you didn't already know a little scared
of this question I guess I learned that
I just don't get sick of you yeah you
don't have many annoying qualities even
at maximum amount of time together you
know what my most annoying quality
recently is to you when I'm in the
passenger seat and I'm open I know what
it is overreacting to your driving look
I grew up in LA to be fair I'm a great
driver from my point of view I'm
aggressive I'm not a good driver and
Dave like hey he's gotten much better
over there the passenger seat what was
the question
I love you yeah quarantine quarantine oh
that you don't get sick of me yeah which
is great great answer that's your first
two pointer
who made the first move
me what was it after our initial
prep you wanna talk to the initial crap
we're in New Orleans at Mardi Gras we're
with my one of my best friends mutual
friends Jules whose mutual friend
invites Dave to dinner with us then at
dinner booze is Flowing readily and and
Dave is sitting next to Jules and Jules
texts me so I check my texts under the
table I have a text from Jules that's
like you should hook up with Dave
tonight and I'm like yes please so
little do I know Jules shows you the
text under the table and is like I don't
listen across the table look at this
idea she goes don't tell her I said
anything I was like great but you did
say I'm in yes as we're leaving that
dinner you come up to me and you say I
have some Molly no this is at the bar
this is at the bar at the next bar that
was the next bar not at dinner though
and I said I have some Molly and I think
we should split it it's probably a great
night this part is correct if it wasn't
if it wasn't my first time taking Molly
it was one of the first times and the
rest of the night we were locked face
locked oh yeah we have some photo
evidence of that and that's the end of
the question what kind of direction do I
give you on set you're great about
giving direction because it's minimal I
think most of the time if anything it's
like less less bring it down like really
grounded you want everything to be very
grounded and real there were so many
times where I would I would run over and
I would come up to you before I even got
there you'd be like I got it and I just
kind of turn around and go back to it
because secretly then ever at the start
of every scene I try to sneak in one
where I get to just
and then I'm like I know Dave doesn't
want me to do that me being in a
situation like that as an actor where
like you know you really give it you get
excited you're like oh it's all here
it's happening and like the director
comes over and he's just like don't do
that and it's like a little
heartbreaking you're like giving you
everything I got but like you were so
great about it you were just like I got
it and then you just ratcheted it back
and basically did what I did at the end
of your round of questions just a little
teary-eyed
hell it comes back to that moment okay
point one point one point what food will
I absolutely never eat mayonnaise and
anything that is a white creamy sauce
There You Go what is our song Oh I found
you by the Alabama Shakes yes yes and we
put an Alabama Shakes song in our movie
and uh Brittany Howard song in our
trailer that's right yeah what's
something not obviously sexual that
turns me on
something not not obviously sexual that
turns you me on just like my butt is
that obviously sexual but like not in a
sexual context like my butt like my bare
ass while I'm brushing my teeth and I've
like taken off my sweats I'm not
committed to being in clothes or out of
clothes that's correct okay we're almost
done we're almost blushing so we're
gonna go to the final question
what do I like most about you
I'm not gonna cry because I because I
don't know I don't know even though you
act like you don't like this about me I
think you do like the fact that I never
stop talking and talk constantly and
tell you every single thing about it
definitely my day and every moment but
of everything that's going on I like
that a lot I don't think that's number
one I like that a lot maybe the number
one thing you like about me my
positivity my optimistic attitude
dancing around the house keeping energy
good and nice
you think so that's correct are your
eyes watering no yeah just like that
feeling where you're just like this free
thing that's so just infectious and you
bring everyone up around you you make
everyone happy and that's the thing you
got this many points no great job great
job
I'm pretty sure it was
yeah
we'll leave it at that thanks for
watching this has been the GQ couples
quiz
oh
I'm more in love with you guys